so we're going to be talking about uh
some new world records uh going 23%
beyond the reman
hypothesis so the reman hypothesis is
one of the great problems in mathematics
with a million-- dooll prize if you
solve it but before I get ahead of
myself let's just talk about our
favorite numbers the primes so the
sequence begins just with 2 3 5 7 11 13
17 19 23 and so on so we know by uclid
the sequence of primes goes on forever
but famously the primes are really known
for being mysterious and having a lot of
complex
so maybe a simpler thing we could look
at is just the last digit so consider
just loing off the other digits and just
considering the ones at the end so it
starts off the same for the single digit
primes 2 3 5 7 and once we get to 11 we
just keep the one at the end 13 we just
keep the three at the end 17 we just
keep the seven at the end and so
on so Brady I'm not so fast writing all
these numbers down especially if they go
on forever maybe with some help of a
computer maybe we can speed up this
process let's just consider looking at
the list of prime numbers up to 100 so
it starts off as before 2 357 but then
it goes up to 97 so that's the largest
prime up to 100 so we look at the last
digit of these primes it starts off
again 2 3 5 7 but then at the end when
we're throwing off we get 89 becomes a 9
97 becomes a 7 the advantage of a
computer here is that we can just change
one character and instead of looking at
primes up to 100 we could look up primes
to 500 and just generates that list uh
pretty readily and if we do the same
thing just looking at the last digit we
get this uh longer table of data as a
mathematician once you see a table of
data you're perk up and you ask uh you
know are there any patterns in this data
um so Brady maybe if we stare at this
table maybe some thoughts going to
emerge which numbers occur frequently
are there any numbers that don't occur
you see anything there are no even
numbers except for the two at the start
and that's because um would be divisible
by two right right so if a number ends
in a two ends in an even number then the
whole number itself is even by a similar
argument maybe a bit more subtle there
are no fives in this list after the the
first five because if a number ends in a
five then the whole number itself has to
be divisible by five uh same zero and
yeah so zero is a double whammy it hits
us both with being even and also being a
multiple of five so what we've just
shown here by this argument is that we
only have a few options here for the
digits that can appear in this list so
so after the single digit numbers
eventually it's either going to be a one
or a three or a s or a 9 and here the
point that you've just figured out is
that the number 10 the base is equal to
2 * 5 so we've just eliminated all the
digits that have a two in it or a five
in it okay so we got these four numbers
the next question I guess people ask is
which are most common yeah I mean that's
that's the that's the question so a
natural thing to do is maybe plot these
numbers on a histogram so let's look at
the numbers up to 100 and look at the
digits so as we said before there's
going to be only one instance of a two
in this and we put them into bins say
one instance of a two similarly there's
G to be one instance of a five and all
the other numbers up to 100 are either
going to have a 1 a three a s or a 9 one
of the great advantages of a computer is
you can just change one character again
and generate a lot more data so if we
look at numbers up to a thousand we can
get these bar charts where these single
entries are getting Slimmer and Slimmer
and these other four bars are getting
taller and taller and maybe if we go
very far let's say we go out to a
million we look at the primes up to a
million and look at their last digit
there's just a tiny sliver corresponding
to two a tiny sliver corresponding to
five and then all these other four
options seems to be almost the same
height so roughly uh a 25% chance of
getting a one as a last digit of a prime
same for three same for seven same for
nine so there's an equal chance to get
any of these four options that is no
coincidence bu this is the prime number
theorem in action we've been playing
this game this fun little game uh
looking at the last digit but really
we've been using the fact that we have
you know 10 fingers on our hands but we
can look at other bases you know for
example computers work in base 2 all
their uh data stored with ones and zeros
so we we can play the same game uh
looking at the last digit uh in other
bases let's just change one line of code
and now uh maybe we get something uh a
bit less interesting here so we get uh
our first uh entry is a zero
corresponding to the prime two and then
all the other primes have their last
digit one in binary so this just means
that all the primes after two are odd
maybe this wasn't as interesting but the
next interesting thing we could look at
is maybe uh base three so we just
increase by one and we look at the prime
written inary and just extract the last
digit so as before we just have a zero
corresponding in this case to the number
three itself but all the other options
for the primes are going to be either a
one or a two for their last digit intern
and so this really again suggests why
don't we play the same game now look in
base three maybe the numers up to a
thousand there's going to be one number
namely three that has atitude zero but
all other numbers are either going to
have a one or a two and again these are
very much dominating maybe if we go up
to a million again we see that the
heights of these two options almost
50/50 split and again this is no
coincidence Brady so you could pick your
favorite base I don't know say 101 uh
and you can have play a similar game you
look at all the last digits of primes uh
in base 101 let's say numbers up to 5
million and you can get a nice uh
roughly uniform distribution and maybe
there's a bit of wiggle room at the top
but as the numbers get larger and larger
The Wiggles start to to to damp out and
you get this result so this is uh kind
of a a fun illustration of one of the
deep results in mathematics the prime
number theorem so people on the channel
may be familiar in this case the prime
number theorem for arithmetic
progressions which says the last digit
of a prime in any base you pick
eventually tends to have an even chance
and that's of course unless there is
some clear reason why there's a
violation so in the case of an even
digit so as long as the digit has no
shared factors with the base we expect
an even spread AC across all options so
maybe to be a bit more precise as a
mathematician I just want to introduce
some math notation Pi ofx here is the
number of primes up to X and the more
precise count that we are interested in
is looking at the number of primes up to
X that have last digit a in base B Pi
has nothing to do with Pi Pi right so
this is one of those things where
mathematicians uh are overloaded with
notation at any time and maybe at some
point in 1700s people decided you know
this was a a convenient letter to to use
for Primes the same uh the same
consonant uh but yeah it's kind of a
stretch so this is the number primes up
to X that have last digit equal to a and
this is written in base B the result of
the prime number theorem tells us in a
more precise way that each of these
options for digits occur with roughly
equal frequency so for any choice of
digit and base Pi of x b comma a we have
this approximate relation that this
count is ASM totic to Pi of X over F of
B so here F of B is the oiler F function
which just counts so F of B is just
counting the number of possible digits
we can use so the number of digits a
that have no uh shared factors with B so
in maybe the mathematical lingo we say
that the gcd the greatest common divisor
of A and B is equal to one yeah so this
is a a nice piece of mathematics that
holds eventually so as X gets larger but
a natural question Brady is maybe you're
a little bit impatient and you want to
know you know how long do I have to wait
uh for this to kick in and those bars
start to even out I mean that depends
how you define even out as well doesn't
right I mean so so there are certainly
very technical like various levels of
technicality how you want to be precise
but morally speaking all we want to know
is how long do we have to go along the
number line to really start to see uh
these numbers evening out but we've now
just with this uh seemingly innocuous
question really gotten through of the
deep end think of you know people
playing around on the shore at the beach
maybe you go snorkeling and around some
Coral but somehow you took a deep dive
and somehow you're now at the bottom of
the marionis trench you're at the
deepest of the deep in mathematics we've
now gotten to the r hypothesis okay so I
really want to narrow in on this this
key relationship in the prime number
theorem which is saying the digits
really even out in their distribution
among the primes so let's give this a
start here so the remon hypothesis
really has to do with answering the how
soon question about star so the remon
hypothesis tells us that star will hold
once we get roughly speaking uh X being
larger than the base squared so this is
a key threshold so in other words the
REM hypothesis or more precisely the
generalized Reon hypothesis says that
this relationship star holds for bases B
that are less than the sare root of x as
x ts to Infinity in other words the
prime number theorem is telling us a a
nice relationship that exists among
primes for any base B we we choose maybe
10 maybe three maybe 101 but the re
hypothesis is really telling us that we
can get the same phenomenon occurring
even if we allow the size of our base to
grow moderately with X with the size of
the numbers I've made videos about the
ran hypothesis before and I don't
pretend to understand it but I've seen
graphs and critical strips and and all
these different numbers but I've never
heard anything about the last digits of
numbers or bases I I mean there are many
ways to approach this uh great Trend to
the r hypothesis so one of the kind of
links with uh the other for perhaps more
standard technical formulation of the
remon hypothesis has to do uh with the
zeros of the reman zeta function
so-called
and their placement on so-called the
critical line of 1/2 and it is no
coincidence that the critical line of
1/2 is the same constant of 1/2
occurring in this threshold of the
square Ro of X so these are these two
relationships are intimately Linked In
This Way okay but I I I I I think this
is a I guess a more downto Earth way to
kind of talk about the remon hypothesis
okay so obviously the reman hypothesis
is one of these kind of white whales of
mathematics that is still unsolved today
but amazingly in the 1960s
mathematicians were able to prove an
average version of this result Bomer and
vinag grov in 1965 they were able to
show that this relationship star holds
for almost all bases B I'm meaning that
this relationship holds for over
99.9% of B's up to this reman hypothesis
range square of X when I first heard
about this result in uh my first year of
uh grad school I thought it was I mean
absolutely stunning because uh I I
somehow felt like the room hypothesis
was you know somehow un unobtainable and
no one's really been able to say
anything about it and so I feel when I
first learned about it I was almost
feeling like uh someone's keeping this
from me so I I really feel someone
should have told me about this earlier
um and the way I like to think about
this result this over 99% result maybe
an analogy with with cleaning cleaning
tools you know if you want to clean
around the house maybe you want to
sanitize your hands you get pel or if
you uh want wanted to clean your
countertop you get Lysol it says on the
label if you read it cleans over 99% of
germs right so this is their real real
selling point and this is because you
know for work around the house 99% of
germs is really more than okay and it's
only really in kind of extreme ideal
circumstances like being a hospital in a
hospital where you need a a full sterile
room uh to get that 100% And so by the
same token as mathematicians uh the
remon hypothesis is really this kind of
Ideal scenario uh getting a full result
that we want to hold but for most
practical purposes as a mathematician in
my research the Bomier venag theorem is
this completely adequate substitute uh
for application for a lot of
applications I'm not having that Jared
I'm not having that because in the
infinite because in the infinite World
of numbers right 99% isn't that much
like there's still a lot of numbers that
it doesn't work for that is definitely
true and obviously this is part of the
conceptual reason why we want to have a
complete understanding but
in one of the kind of facets of the Reon
hypothesis is that people have proven
many results uh with the initial caveat
assume the Reon hypothesis then and
there were many results in the 1960s
that went from a conditional uh
hypothesis to uh complete Ironclad
theorem once this uh result came out and
it turns out in some technical settings
it is enough to just know this 99%
version to get the desired end goal if
you were using the r hypothesis
implicitly in your work but if they
found uh a power an exponent where
fear's Last Theorem broke there was like
one number out there where Andrew WS
this building wouldn't be named after
Andrew Wes yeah yeah so you know as a
mathematician you really want to get
that complete understanding and
exceptional cases can really uh be
important and so this also ties in with
uh previous uh things on the channel
about zal zeros which are these
potential real uh monsters is uh trying
to thwart the Reon hypothesis before
this I mean I just want to emphasize how
kind of amazing I find this because
before this result no one really knew
anything like you couldn't uh you
couldn't really say uh much at all uh
and really taking the statistical
perspective uh has really been leading
to a flourishing in in mathematical
research so this is well not again the
the ideal scenario but for most
practical purposes as a working
mathematician around the house uh this
this is really kind of an important uh
tool in the toolkit okay I believe you
so now we get now we get to the real uh
the real be once presented with this
result and if we're if we're only
looking at some of the bases and not all
a question comes up another question we
asked how soon but if we're only looking
at some of the bases can we go even
sooner can we get a rate of convergence
faster than what the remon hypothesis is
predicting so can we get uh bases B that
are Beyond this square root X barrier so
in other words Brady I'm asking to go
beyond the REM hypothesis it was uh
remarkable results in the 1980s that
actually first uh made a proof of
concept showing we have this what is X
again remind me what x actually is so X
is the size of the numbers the size of
the primes were going up to so sometimes
it was like 100 sometimes it a thousand
a million and this gets these these uh
bar charts get more and more refined as
as X gets larger but really the the meat
and potatoes of the question is
how soon can we go even sooner that's
how soon they start evening yeah but how
are you defining evening yeah so I mean
uh you can measure and for example look
at the difference between uh the desired
quantity and then the the expected
average and then so you know in
statistics you have the concept of a a
mean or kind of the average of a
distribution and then also the variance
or the standard deviation and so you can
ask more technical questions about
looking at the standard deviation this
is really what the REM hypothesis is all
about so this is kind of the second
order question about the distribution of
primes so we have this of course uh
result from 1965 which gets this uh
reman hypothesis on average bound but
this was improved remarkably in the
1980s getting exponents up to x to the
571 so the way to interpret this Brady
this breakthrough is we went 15% beyond
the r hypothesis and this result really
for almost 40 years was the
state-ofthe-art
going beyond the r hypothesis until
about two years ago where James Maynard
uh actually extended this result so in
2021 he found that there were some bases
that you could take all the way up to ex
the 60 so in other words we can go up to
20% beyond the Reon hypothesis so after
almost a four decade uh Hiatus uh
there's been progress on the problem by
James mayard who fans of the channel
he's up he's up there somewhere yeah
office is up there we should have got
him in here yeah and so today I'm happy
to say that we can get even further up
to be up to 617 in other words we can go
23% beyond the remon hypothesis what
does that mean so this means that there
are some bases B of up to this size
going beyond the re hypothesis range for
which the primes in that base have their
digits being kind of nicely uh
distributed as we would expect so we
only have to wait a shorter amount of
time 23% uh less time than we would
expect from the r hypothesis before they
start flattening out before so so this
is kind of a savings of time uh in one
sense in other words we can take more
bases and this result is holding for for
more uh base B
expansions do we know what any of these
bases are uh so that's one of uh maybe
the kind of aspects of this more
statistical approach is that we're
looking at families of numbers and so
one of the insights all all the way
going back to the bum vagr theorem is
that if you look at collections of
numbers or families of numbers together
you can gain additional insights that
might not be as a parent from looking at
an individual number so we can't
necessarily pinpoint an exact B that
this holds but we can still have a
family uh that's of a larger size and
again maybe in in an ideal scenario we
can try to prove the remon hypothesis
and we can prove these nice results for
every single B but in many practical
applications these kinds of results are
are very useful we'd actually expect
this to hold for all the bases but
that's
again beyond what so even if you prove
the REM hypothesis this would be a
question yet beyond what we can do there
so that's maybe far off in the distance
for future generations to think about
but at least from a statistical point of
view this is uh I feel U making good
progress we know that it holds for base
two three four yeah so for any for any
individual fixed number already the
prime number theorem is telling us that
we get this nice convergence but it's
only when the bases are allowed to grow
moderately um we we want to be able to
quantify that rate of growth so uh
already we know U even by the zle
wolfish theorem which was proven over
about 100 years ago we can allow the
base to grow logarithmically or very
very slowly with X and not run into
trouble but really you you have to
assume these very heavyweight
conjectures like the reman hypothesis if
you want an individual B to be growing
uh like up to the square of X these
kinds of results uh I feel have a very
uh beautiful aspect where they connect
so that the proof ideas that go into
them connect a wide range of ideas
across maybe seemingly disparate areas
of math so on the one hand uh some ideas
that go into this relate to modular
forms these kind of exotic objects uh
that actually ended up playing a crucial
role for example in fatula theorem
proven by Andrew ws and has led to the
Lang Lance programs um on the other hand
uh it uses results from algebra geometry
uh more specifically the the V bound and
the Del bound from the so-called reman
hypothesis for Curves over finite Fields
uh which is itself another story for
another time but I just want to convey
the sense that a lot of uh there's a
Confluence of a lot of ideas coming
together just to uh make progress on
understanding the distribution of just
the primes and as a just a last shout
out so I wanted to say that there seems
to be a kind of nice Revival in this
field of studying these questions uh in
the last maybe decade where there before
had been something something of a lull
and I just wanted to shout out some
people s drao y marosi Lassa grimel and
Alex pascarti who are who have been uh
doing some interesting work and we've
been having a nice discussion so it's
really good to see this uh flourishing
of this this
subject 100 between one and 1,000
between one and 1 million for any uh n
between one and N using his zeta
function which is absolutely astonishing
because if you think about zeta function
something has to do with complex numbers
and with analytic continuation and so on
and so forth so it's a particular branch
of mathematics which is called complex
analysis but prime
numbers live in a different branch of
mathematics it tells us things we
already suspect because we sort of
believe the ran hypothesis is true but
there things we can't prove so for
example how many primes are there up to
a trillion we have a formula for that
that we believe is true but we can only
prove that formula if we know the ran
hypothesis is true